is the 24 core m1 max chip the actual  sweet spot compared to the 16 core and  the 32 core especially on the 14 inch  macbook pro from what i know now is  probably the best m1 max chip to buy  if you care about bank for the buck well  where are they why are there barely any  information and benchmarks and tests  posted online why have we still not got  ours what i ended up doing is looking at  luke's videos create a tech and running  their tests with the exact same settings  they did that's where we're gonna take a  look at gfx bench's aztec runes we're  only going from 242 on the 24 core to  272 on the 32 so that performance isn't  that much greater for the extra cost  apple is just having really good results  with the 32 core options and there are  just not enough 24 cores and they rather  make that extra 200 bucks that's the  only thing that i can really think of